so Aaron you play a lot of shooters I'm
curious to see what you think of toxic
because it's pretty much the complete
opposite of every shooter that's come
out in the last half decade it's got no
iron sights it's got no customization of
classes no skill trees it's got none of
the bells and whistles that we have on
new games graphics will be all text base
you know it adds graphics that's
basically Unreal Tournament looks like
they're trying to bring that style of
gameplay back although I don't know man
if you don't have any unlocked reen and
you don't have cover and you don't aim
down sights like you also might not have
a reason for players to keep playing
your game titanfall
did have all those things and now you
can log on to a server and there's about
six people at any given time that
doesn't necessarily keep people in these
games for a long time so it's really
going back to a different era of
shooting it's just I'm curious to see
whether or not modern modern shooting
fans will you know take to that or
they'll be turned off by it you know
vehicle combat always adds a little bit
of depth to games no like the people who
don't like to aim down sights play
counter-strike these days what a guy who
grew up playing Call of Duty er grew up
playing battlefield want to go back to
the fast-paced movement and like just
insanity of the unreal style it's also
not not not free-to-play meaning you do
have to pay for it I think that's a
pretty good angle to go because a lot of
the murkiness of games these days and a
lot of the complaints for more core
shooting audiences is that the
free-to-play market is sort of you know
dirtying the water so to speak that
things like Team Fortress 2 when they
came out with these fantastic shooters
that had a really unique experience and
we're sort of fast paced and had a lot
of that art heating this to them but
then as soon as it turned into you know
people wearing 16 hats and running
around looking like cartoon characters
it just it no longer was the same thing
it was more of like a collection
simulator
they're really marketing just what is in
a shooter like it has gun this is like
your mouse has two buttons on it
skill-based from using the WS ad keys if
you have skull you can skill shot in
pretty much I think you could skill shot
in World of Warcraft if you were good
enough I'm you know personally excited
to see a shooter that's intentionally
trying to deviate from the norm and you
know I guess we'll see or whether that's
going back to the old norm yeah yeah for
sure it's it's not new it's just old new
you